I wish that I could say
let's put 2020 behind us
and never think about it again.
But I'm afraid we have to look back
at what was for many
a very exhausting year
and do something only slightly
less exhausting, our taxes.
2020 brings with it all kinds
of special considerations
when it comes to your income tax filing.
Stimulus payments, did
you receive unemployment,
working from home?
Let's put on some chill new age music
and see if we can demystify some of this.
So let's say somebody
lost their job last year
and they received those
enhanced unemployment benefits.
What does that mean for their tax filing?
Very important, unemployment is taxable
and they have to make
sure that it's included
on this 2020 return.
They are not gonna get
the form directly mailed,
it appears to them.
They're gonna have to go
online and get the 1099-G form
that will tell them how much is taxable
and if they paid any
taxes in advance on them.
What about the stimulus payments
people have been getting?
The stimulus payments are not taxable.
So you do not have to
worry about reporting it
when you get to your return.
Some people didn't get
benefits of a stimulus payment
who deserved it.
If your income was higher
in 2019 taxes that they used
or 2018, you may have
not gotten the stimulus
because your income was too high.
But lo and behold, 2020
comes and you made less money
and you now qualify.
So you can now apply for
the stimulus payments
when you file your 2020 taxes
and get what you didn't get
because your income was too high
when they based it on the prior year.
What is the home office deduction
and how can I take advantage of it?
That's been a question that
many people are asking.
If you have your own business,
yes, the home office deduction
is yours for the taking.
If there's a room you use for business
and you don't have an office that you use.
But the bad news is a few years ago,
they changed the deduction for people
who are on W2 for employees.
So an employee cannot take
any employee business expenses
as a deduction, including
the home office deduction.
So let's say that I am that freelancer.
There are certain items
that I'm buying specifically
for work that I want to deduct at 100%.
Can you tell me if they
are legit deductions?
Go for it.
Okay, office plant.
I'm gonna give you that one.
The plant is exclusively for
your office and the office
is exclusively business,
I'll give you the plant.
A new laptop computer.
If it's exclusively used for business,
then 100% would be used for business.
If you don't have a personal computer,
the IRS would say keep your time,
deduct that percentage of the laptop.
How about children's books?
I have to give you a nay on that one.
How about books that advance my career?
Continuing education,
whether it's a seminar,
a book would be deductible.
And what about meals?
So meals are deductible
if business is conducted.
Meals are 50% deductible.
There is a change I
wanna mention for 2021.
Meals are gonna be 100% deductible.
That helps to stimulate the economy
and get us all out going there.
When should people file their taxes?
If you're able and you have the forms,
the earlier the better to file.
There's a lot of people
stealing people's identity
and you wanna claim your identity first.
Easiest way, file early.
How do charitable donations
affect your taxes?
In years past, unless you
itemized deductions, not much.
Yeah, so this is actually a change
that Congress has talked
about for a long time
and was finally able to get done
in the CARES Act, which passed last March.
We wanna demonstrate that we do care
for the American people in every way.
What Congress said is,
look, even if you take
the standard deduction,
you can get a tax break of up to $300
for charitable donations.
So typically, that was only
limited to people who itemized.
So it was a big deal.
Congress' thinking here
is this was a way for them
to get more money out to groups
that were helping people
during the pandemic
without specifically sending
them a check directly.
And whenever you donate to charity,
you're going to wanna make sure
that that organization is
putting your money to good use.
But how do you do that?
Charity Navigator is the nation's
and actually for that matter,
the world's largest independent
evaluator of nonprofits.
We get to help donors
find strong organizations
to make donations to.
You wanna know you're giving to a 501
legitimate nonprofit organization.
And that's where we
really can be very helpful
because our database has the full list
of legally registered organizations.
If you don't find it, it may not be real.
And that's an important
thing to know about.
Getting audited, now,
that's a scary prospect.
And one strange or slightly
infuriating aspect of it
is that those who make
very little get audited
just about as much as
those who make a lot.
It's true, an investigation
by ProPublica last year
revealed that over the last 10 years,
audits for those claiming
the earned income tax credit,
the nation's largest anti-poverty
program, remains steady.
While millionaires were 80% less likely
to be audited than they were in 2011.
All of this might lead you to believe
that if you're ultra wealthy,
the system works a bit
differently for you.
I'm Ben Steverman, I
cover wealth at Bloomberg.
Okay, Ben, let's say I'm a newly-minted
ultra wealthy person.
How do I make sure that
Uncle Sam doesn't take
even a substantial portion of my income?
If you have a bunch of
wealth, you have an advantage
over people like me or you who
every time we get a paycheck,
the IRS knows about it
and they're gonna expect
their cut of that.
We don't have a control over
when we can take income,
but wealthy people do.
And I think that's the
key to the advantage
that wealthy people have on
avoiding taxes on their income.
We have situations where
people have billions of dollars
but are only reporting maybe
10, $20 million in income
in a given year.
Wait, how is that possible?
The best example is probably Jeff Bezos.
His wealth comes from Amazon.com
and he's worth almost $200 billion.
However, he hasn't paid taxes
yet on a good portion of that
because all that wealth
is just in the share price
of Amazon going up and
he hasn't sold that many
of those shares.
The thing is that if he
never sells those shares
or if he can somehow
transfer them to his kids,
he might never have to
pay taxes on that money.
That's a loophole that is in the law.
Joe Biden has actually said
that he wants to change that rule.
The rule is called stepped-up basis.
And this idea that when
your kids or whoever
inherits your money, all those
gains that would be taxable
are wiped out and they can start fresh.
And they never have to pay taxes on that.
But if his fortune is all in stock shares,
how can he afford to buy anything?
So you can borrow against shares,
you can borrow against buildings you own.
That's something that Donald Trump
and other real estate developers do.
You can use that debt to
maybe finance your lifestyle.
And you're probably gonna
be okay as long as the value
of those assets you're borrowing
against continues to rise
and then you can continue
to refinance that money.
Geez, so I guess the lesson
here is to stop working a job
and become a high net
worth shareholder then.
Yes, investors pay much
lower rates than workers do,
even if we're talking
about the working rich.
The working rich can end
up paying a top tax rate
of about 50% if you're looking
at New York or California,
which have the top income tax rates.
But these are people
like doctors and actors
and entertainers and athletes
that end up paying this rate.
It's not investors because
capital gains and dividends
are taxed at a much lower rate.
Donald Trump paying 750
or almost nothing in taxes
is maybe an extreme example of something
that business owners do all the time.
Because you control these
businesses, you're able
to generate losses that maybe
are just losses on paper
but they can help offset other income.
One of the billionaire's
favorite things to do is
to buy a sports team.
Sports teams are wonderful
for creating paper losses.
There's this idea of depreciation.
Let's say you build a factory.
The value of that factory is
gonna lose value over time
just naturally and the IRS
says, okay, well, you can deduct
that loss of value of wear
and tear and everything
on your taxes.
Well, sports teams, real estate
buildings have the same rule
and you're able to
depreciate those over time,
even if the actual value of those things
like the sports team for
example is actually going up.
The wealthy can hire very
expensive advisors who can come up
with these schemes to lower
their tax burden or avoid
not just the income tax
but the estate tax as well.
So the other thing that's
happened is that the IRS budget
has just been slashed over
the last several years.
You actually have about
40% fewer agents employed
by the IRS than were employed in 2010.
So you have a situation where
nobody's really checking
a lot of this stuff.
My W2, your W2, your paycheck,
the IRS has computer systems
that can quickly analyze
that and figure out
that, oh, you didn't pay taxes.
But if I set up some
complex trust strategy
using offshore vehicles
and then I'm also taking
all this depreciation off of my business
and reported all these
losses off of my business
and oh, by the way, I'm
employing some family members
at that business, there
are so many different ways
that a business owner and an investor
can just structure things
in very complex ways
that the IRS just really
doesn't have the resources
to even take a look.
And that's why people are saying we need
to spend a lot more money on
the IRS and that if we did so,
we could actually find
trillions of dollars possibly
in new revenue just from people
who aren't paying their taxes
or who are using some questionable
schemes to avoid taxes.
So if you can't get that
tricky with your income taxes,
just remember that stimulus
payments aren't taxed,
unemployment payments are
and this one's gonna hurt,
but file as early as possible.